no matter how fast you are
i am not to be compared to you no one
outruns their past
[Music]
welcome to your weekly ticket
well the fast and furious saga is coming
to an end with a two-part movie over
fast 10 and fast 11.
originally universal had planned to
debut its latest chapter f9 in theaters
this year but that release was delayed
due to covet 19.
both fast 10 and fast 11 will be
directed by justin lin
and while the cast has not yet been
confirmed it's expected that returning
cast members vin diesel
michelle rodriguez tyrese gibson and
ludacris will appear
tom holland has just shared a first look
at his character from the upcoming film
uncharted pollen will play a younger
version of the video game hero
nathan drake and the movie is set to be
an origin story for the character
the original nathan drake voice actor
nolan north also shared a few images
from the set which
included himself talking to holland
ancient ruins and some mystical
artifacts that are likely to appear in
the film
ruben fleischer is set to direct the
film which has been in the works for
about a decade
in addition to holland mark wahlberg
antonio banderas sophia taylor ali and
tati gabriel
are also set to star and just like that
holland is off to star on his next
project
spider-man 3. okay so
we just landed in atlanta and uh
[Music]
it's time for spider-man 3. let's go the
meg is getting a sequel and a director
just got on board
warner brothers has tapped british
filmmaker ben wheatley to direct the meg
too
much of the film's cast will likely
return including jason statham who
portrayed a u.s navy diver sent to
rescue divers from a shark attack
a giant prehistoric shark attack there's
no word yet on when production will
begin on the sequel
well we're rounding out the spookiest
month of the year by taking a look at
some of our
favorite horror films and celebrating
the female leads
in them with fandango now's list of
horror heroines
there's no one better to help us out
with this list of horror heroines
than horror vet actor producer barbara
crampton
hey barbara how you doing hey how are
you kale nice to see you
nice to see you too we often hear the
term scream queen
versus final girl can you give us a
little bit of history
on those tropes and how they've changed
yeah i believe that it was fay ray
who uh first received that moniker after
she did king kong and
really it's a moniker that has continued
to this day
it went on and continued on with people
who are
so famous in the genre like jamie lee
curtis and others
but i have to tell you even fay ray and
jamie lee curtis were not fans of that
term
scream queen and i am definitely not a
fan of that term as well i think
it's i will admit that a lot of people
use that term
fondly but to me it feels like it
pigeonholes
women into seeming like they're like
shrieking damsels in distress and they
need help and they need somebody to come
and save them
and believe me with all the strong women
i know we are
perfectly capable of handling ourselves
and fighting our own battles yeah
absolutely i you
famously penned an op-ed called like not
using the term scream queen
please don't call me a screen question
please okay
yeah and you have to read it like you
just said it
exactly so what do you think feels
different about horror
now versus like the 80s you know horror
is
one of the most lucrative genres it it
never fails to make money
and i think hollywood is just catching
up to that now i mean we've seen movies
like get out and the shape of water
and parasite and a quiet place and films
like that
and i think that in the old days
we did probably just kind of
relate to the more basic levels
of what people were looking for of women
screaming of a lot of blood of some sort
of masculine
going after people but now it feels like
we're telling the stories in a more
nuanced way
and we're telling them through things
that are really
happening in our world and they just
feel
they just feel more emotional and more
true
and i think that's super smart so i i
think that's why hollywood has
been getting involved in horror lately
they're disguising it as a drama or when
it's
when people say oh the shape of water is
a horror movie or why place
well quiet place is definitely a horror
movie get out as a horror movie
they go oh well no we don't want to call
it a horror movie
per se but we definitely want the money
that that
horror movie genre brings in so i feel
like
hollywood is not being honest with um
how they're dealing with the horror
genre and what it's
paved the way for what it's been giving
to all of us sure yeah another great
example of that would be invisible man
which turns out to be like about
emotional abuse in
a lot of ways so yeah it was like a me
too movie in a way
right yeah that's a great that's a great
movie but yeah a lot of nuances in that
yes
and movie stars are now really wanting
to do horror films
oh yeah yeah i'd love to see some people
start to cross over
yeah so now this is a question i've been
really looking forward to asking you
what who is like one of your favorite
horror actresses
from this list let me say that elizabeth
moths is on that list
i mean i love her in the handmaid's tale
i loved her an invisible man
i mean i think she's just internal and
you can
you know and and and they play to her
they play
to what's on her face and she's shown in
a lot of close-ups because
she gives you that she can play with her
emotions in a way that a lot of other
actors really can't do she goes places
that other people can't go
at the drop of a hat so i would say
elizabeth moss is a very affecting
actor i have to give my hats off to
[ __ ] spacek from carrie i feel like
she's a fantastic actress and did a
great job in gary fay ray is one of my
favorites i mean
she is our ultimate you know if we go
back
in history to someone who gave the way
for all of us
of new people right now i'd say i really
like jessica roth
yes yeah absolutely we need more jessica
roth
we absolutely need more of her she's
very entertaining
she's an entertainer she's a good
actress she can do
comedy and she can do drama she can be
very scared but she's also very
exuberant
and that to me has been such
a beautiful thing to see and witness her
career over the past few years
because i feel like we you know recently
we were in this period of mumblecore
where everybody was trying to out
naturalize everybody else and just be
regular and cool and and i just feel
like
she's put some life back into acting
again and she's just an exciting
performer to watch so yeah yeah but
happy death day
uh is a is a great is a great film but
like
you're just so excited to watch her go
through what's happening
he is yes yes he loves it exciting
performer
i love it if anyone watching this hasn't
seen happy death day or happy death day
to you you
absolutely have to watch it i love both
of them yeah the trailer does not do
enough justice to that movie what do you
hope to see
from future horror films i really would
like to see us go a little bit
more mainstream and accepted i feel like
we're we're more accepted than we were
maybe 20 years ago or 10 years ago
i'd like to see more film i mean
parasite and shame water did well
you know award season so i i just like
to see people
just accept us as something
that is more mainstream that you would
you would gravitate towards seeing i
hear a lot of people say
i don't want to go to a horror movie
because i don't like to be scared well
we are scared every day with our
political uh system that's going on
right now
i live in fear every moment of my life
i'm cringing
a horror movie allows you to go
through these experiences and
usually and hopefully come out on the
other side
winning or being able to have a
satisfying conclusion
with the bad guys dead and the good guys
surviving
and so i think we need to you know have
more experience with that on a visceral
level
watching horror movies i think they're
actually very therapeutic
and i and i feel like some people are
afraid of horror movies but when they
watch them they go oh that actually
wasn't as scary as i thought
you know that was a good film so i'd
like like to see us sort of
weaved into the fabric of other genres
a little bit more perfectly said well
thank you so much barbara crampton for
coming on where can people find you
well come over my address is no just
kidding
that's a first let's go everybody weekly
ticket let's go
party at farmer's house um you know it's
just my name
i'm on pretty much everything instagram
facebook and twitter
barbara crampton fantastic thank you so
much for coming on the show it's been a
blast
thanks available to watch in theaters on
friday
is come play just want to
oliver a lonely young boy who feels
different from everyone else
seeks solace and refuge in his
ever-present cell phone and tablet
when a mysterious creature uses oliver's
devices against him to break into our
world
oliver's parents must fight to save
their son from the monster beyond the
screen
and available to watch at home on friday
is spell
this it stands for you
whatever happens to it happens
to you while flying to his father's
funeral in rural appalachia an intense
storm causes marquis to lose control of
the plane carrying himself
and his family he soon awakens wounded
alone and trapped in ms
eloise's attic eloise claims she can
nurse him back to health with a hoodoo
figure she's made from his blood and
skin
unable to call for help marquis
desperately tries to break free from her
dark magic
and save his family from a sinister
ritual before the rise of the blood moon
alright that's it for today but check
out that full list of horror heroines
and leave us a comment and let us know
which one is your
favorite i'm kale and i'll see you next
[Music]
time